Even though I walk through the valley of the shadow
of death, I will not fear for you are with me.
You are my light and my salvation.
You restore me and lead me for your glory.
I long to dwell in your house forever.
Well, good morning, if you would please open your Bibles
to Psalm 73.
Psalm 73. I'm glad you're here this morning.
Uh, my name is Aaron Ferguson
and I'm one of the elders here at Henderson Hills
and it's my privilege to
study Psalm 73 with you this morning.
While you're turning there, I wanna wish you a happy moon
landing day.
It's actually yesterday,
but as a teacher of American history, I keep track
of these sorts of things.
On July 20th, 1969,
the Apollo 11 mission landed
Neil Armstrong
and Buzz Aldrin on the moon in the Eagle, one
of the most watched events in world history,
some 600 million viewers.
And of course we got those famous words,
the eagle has landed.
Yeah. And then Neil first man
to step foot on the moon uttered that profound statement.
That's one small step for man, one giant
leap for mankind.
Yeah, I guess you could say he understood the
gravity of the situation.
Um, anyway, that goes down in history as one
of the greatest statements that uh, anyone has ever made.
What did they do on the moon?
They spent quite a bit of time gathering rocks.
They drove the buggy down to uh, moon River
and they uh,
They went to Starbucks, got a latte.
Anyway, they did some other things.
You'll be interested to know
that since 1969 they've been back to the moon six times.
They've also set up a, uh, space station,
the Hubble Telescope and other things.
And of course they built a new restaurant.
If you haven't heard, uh, critics say the food is great,
but there's no atmosphere.
So, so sorry.
Don't fact check me on any of that. Okay.
My students at school, they, they've learned to, uh,
believe about half of what I say.
And so anyway, I know that gives you great confidence
as we go into uh, Psalm 73.
But anyway, we are in a 15 year
series on the book of Psalms
and we've made it almost halfway.
Psalm 73, the uh, Psalms are just
songs, poems set to music.
Uh, there's five books.
They're arranged in five books with about eight authors,
maybe more than that.
Books one and two. We just finished last week,
mostly written by King David.
And you'll notice today
as you look at Psalm 73 right there somewhere,
it should say book three.
So book three opens with Psalm 73 goes through Psalm 89,
and most of these are written by a man named asap.
You'll see maybe a super script right there
underneath Psalm 73, Psalm written by asap.
So who is this ASAP character?
It would be helpful to know before we dive in to Psalm 73.
ASAP appears several times in one Chronicles chapter six
and 16 and 25
and some other places, he's a Levite.
And if you remember, the sons of Levi, the descendants
of Levi were assigned by God to take care of the tabernacle
or the the temple King David even assigned some
of them to lead worship.
So when you went to the temple, you heard worship music
and ASAP was one of those worship leaders.
So he's a songwriter, he's a skilled musician,
the Bible says, and even a prophet,
and he's more than uh, uh, 12
Psalms are attributed to asap.
So this is asap.
I wish we had time to dive in a little more deeply on
who the man is, but we have a long
Psalm ahead of us this morning.
So I want to dive right in.
What does ASAP want us to know in Psalm 73?
Well, if you'll join me there, let's read it together,
28 verses.
But this is fantastic.
Psalm says this verse one, truly God is good
to Israel to those who are pure in heart.
But as for me, my feet had almost stumbled.
My steps had nearly slipped for I was envious
of the arrogant when I saw the prosperity of the wicked.
For they had no pains or pain until death.
Their bodies were fat and sleek, meaning healthy.
They are not in trouble as others are.
They are not stricken like the rest of mankind.
Therefore, pride is their necklace.
Violence covers them as a garment.
Their eyes swell out through fatness.
Don't you hate when that happens?
They didn't have the word bulge back in that day.
Uh, their eyes were bulging, greedy.
Their hearts overflow with follies, they scoff
and speak with malice or hatred.
Lawfully. They threaten oppression.
They set their mouths against the heavens
and their tongues struts through the earth.
Therefore, his people turn back to them
and find no fault in them and
and they say, how can God know
as their knowledge in the most high behold,
these are the wicked always at ease
and they increase in riches.
So he is looking around and he sees the wicked,
how good they have it, and then he looks at
himself and look what he says.
Verse 13, all in vain have I kept my heart clean
and washed my hands in innocence for all day long.
I've been stricken and rebuked every morning.
If I had said I will speak,
thus I would've betrayed the generation of your children.
He didn't want to admit his doubts of God to anybody else.
Verse 16. But when I thought how to understand this,
it seemed to me a wearisome task until I went
to the sanctuary of God
and then I discerned their end.
Truly, you set them in slippery places.
You make them fall to ruin
how they are destroyed in a moment swept away utterly
by terrors like a dream.
When one awake so Lord, you rouse yourself, you despise them
as phantoms or ghosts in a bad dream.
When my soul was embittered, when I was pricked
and hard, I was brutish and ignorance.
I was like a beast towards you.
Nevertheless, I am continually with you.
You hold my right hand, you guide me with your counsel
and afterward you'll receive me to glory.
And then he finishes with this, whom have I in heaven
but you and there is nothing on earth I desire besides you.
My flesh and my heart may feel that God is the strength
of my heart and my portion forever.
For behold, those who are far from you shall perish.
You put an end to everyone who is unfaithful to you.
But as for me, it is good to be near God.
I have made the Lord God my refuge that I may tell
of all your works.
Let's pray together and ask God to
bless our time and his word.
Lord, we're grateful for Psalm 73 this morning, grateful for
ASAP and the wisdom that you've given him.
Help us apply the truth of your word today
to our lives and let us see our circumstances in a new
eternal perspective.
It's in Christ name we pray. Amen.
Well, in Psalm 73, Asaf has a crisis
of faith, a crisis of faith.
Have you ever had a crisis of faith, maybe circumstances
that challenged what you believe
or maybe something that's pushed you so far
that you doubted God or distrusted God?
What do you do in a moment like that?
How do you respond to a crisis of faith?
Well, let me first define a crisis just
so we're all on the same page.
I'm gonna give you two definitions.
First definitions from Noah Webster's 1828 dictionary.
A crisis is the decisive state of things
or the point of time when an affair has arrived at its
height and must soon terminate
or suffer a change.
Note the word change here, crisis leads to change.
dictionary.com, little more modern definition,
a crisis is a turning point for better
or worse, a condition of instability
or danger leading to
a decisive change.
Both definitions tell us that crisis
produces change.
Something has to change.
Either the crisis changes
or you do something has to change.
That's what the word crisis means.
The truth is though, you're always going to have
crazy circumstances in your life,
you're always gonna have crises, right?
You're either in a crisis
or you're about to go into a crisis
or you're coming out of a crisis
or always have crazy circumstances in our life.
So what needs to change is not the fact
that we're gonna have crises, but how we view them,
our perspective of our circumstances,
and asaps gonna help us by sharing his experience.
I have broken down this long
28 verse Psalm into three sections.
First, Asaf encounters a crisis.
We'll look at a crisis that he encounters.
Second ASAP evaluates his crisis,
and third Asaf ends his crisis.
What changes? Let's look a little more closely at these
three sections.
What crisis did Asaf encounter?
Look back at verses two and three with me.
He started with my feet nearly slipped. Why?
Why did his feet nearly slip?
He, he says this, I was envious
of the arrogant when I saw the prosperity of the wicked,
I saw how good bad people had it
and then I began to look at myself.
Look at verses 13 and 14, all in vain.
What a waste of time have I kept my heart clean
and wash my hands in innocence for all day long?
I've been stricken and rebuked every morning.
So what's the crisis that he's facing here?
He's looking around at the world
and he sees bad people have it so good
and good people have it so bad.
That's the crisis that he's facing.
If you look at verse four, bad people live pain-free lives.
So he thinks also in verse four,
the wicked are healthy and strong.
Verse five, they don't have troubles like everyone else.
Verses six through nine, they are prideful and cruel
and yet they have it all.
Verse 11, they boast that God is ignorant
and he can't see what's going on.
Verse 12, they are at ease
and they're increasing and they're riches.
And then verse 16, he tries to understand it
and he just can't make sense of it all.
Now, ASAP has done all the right things and his mind
and yet these evil people were better off than he
was and that's not fair.
Have you ever said those words, that's not fair.
Or why God,
why am I suffering when other people aren't?
Why do I have to go through this?
Why is this happening to me?
How can there be a good God with all the evil in the world?
God must not be just or loving. Don't you love me?
God, we've all been there.
How do you reconcile what you see and feel
and experience with
what you know about God?
Your faith in God? Be very, very careful right here.
There's a ditch that believers often fall into
and you'll notice that ASAP nearly di if you look back at
verse two, he said, my feet almost stumbled.
I almost fell right here.
'cause of my circumstances, my steps nearly slipped. Why?
When you're in these crazy circumstances
or you have a crisis, you really have two options
and Asaf had both options.
Here are your two options.
You can either trust God with your circumstances
or you can trust your understanding of your circumstances.
You can trust God with your circumstances
Now you are familiar with Proverbs three, five, trust
in the Lord Solomon says with all your heart
and do not lean on your own understanding in all your ways,
even your difficulties, even your hard circumstances.
Acknowledge him and he will make straight your past.
In the first half of Psalm 73, 3,
Asaf is evaluating his circumstances
with his own understanding
and we do that all the time, don't we?
He came to verse 16.
He actually uses the word, when I thought how
to understand this, it seemed to me a weary some task.
He couldn't make sense of it all.
In fact, his understanding led him
to assume some wrong conclusions about God.
God's not fair. God's not just God doesn't love me.
He almost abandoned his faith.
He says, I almost stumbled, almost fell.
Wait, that's the ditch that I warned about.
Please hear me. We often are guilty
of evaluating God's character
by our circumstances when we should be evaluating our
circumstances by God's character.
That's a lot of words, but lemme say that again.
We are often guilty of evaluating or judging God
and his character by our circumstances.
God, I know you're this,
but look what's happening to me just like ASAP was doing
when we should be evaluating our
circumstances by God's character.
What do I mean? Go back to verses 16 and 17.
This is the turning point of Psalm 73.
When I thought how to understand this, Asaf says, it seemed
to me a weary some task until I went
to the sanctuary of God
and then I discerned there end
asap went to the sanctuary of God, he went to the temple,
the place where God dwelled in Jerusalem,
the place of worship where he led music
and they were reminded of all the Psalms of David
and he began to ponder the truth in those psalms
and he began to realize, I've got it all wrong.
He began to have his eyes opened
and he began to have a new perspective.
It was in the sanctuary of God
that he got an eternal perspective.
His eyes were open.
He saw the big picture in the sanctuary
of God when he turned his attention to God
and contemplated who God is and what he says.
He came to his senses. Verse 17, I discerned therein.
I realized where I was wrong in the wrong ways
that I was thinking I wanna stop right here
and stress the significance of scripture intake.
Scripture intake may not have ever heard that phrase before,
but you and I must regularly be reading,
studying God's word, scripture, intake, taking it in,
absorbing it, meditating on it.
You and I need to be at church.
You need to be in a small group Bible study.
You need to be exposing yourself to sound
biblical teaching regularly.
Why? Because these things remind us of who God is
and what he says, and we can evaluate our circumstances in
light of who he is and what he says.
Go to the sanctuary of God.
You're familiar with Psalm 1 19, 1 0 5, thy word is a
lamp into my feet and a light into my path.
We've got to be regularly going to the sanctuary of God,
going into the presence of God.
I know God is with you all of the time. He's for believers.
He's indwelling you, but you know what I mean.
Getting in the presence of God, getting into God's word,
getting into God's house helps you to see
your circumstances with an eternal perspective.
Be careful not to evaluate
or judge God's character by your circumstances.
Rather evaluate your circumstances by God's character.
What does that mean? Evaluate your circumstances in light of
who God is.
In other words, don't start with your circumstances
and try to figure things out.
Don't start with your understanding.
Don't go to the world
and see what the world has to say about your circumstances.
Start with God. Take every thought captive.
Paul would say, what does that mean?
Here's what I mean by that. Ask yourself these questions.
What does God say about himself?
What does God say about you?
What does God say about your circumstances,
the world around you?
What does God have to say about this?
Start with him and not your understanding.
Where do we find the answers to those things?
We find them in God's word.
Listen, in a time of crisis, which we're all going through
crazy circumstances, current events right now,
right in our country, it's important that you go
to God's word and speak truth to yourself.
Speak truth to yourself just like Philippians four,
eight says, whatever is true, think on those things.
It's important when your circumstances are crazy,
speak truth to yourself.
That's what asaps gonna do. He meditates on four truths.
I wanna walk you through the four truths
that he meditates on.
Truth number one in a crisis.
Truths you need to tell yourself.
You need to remind yourself. Truth number one, God is good.
God is good. I don't mean that he can do good sometimes.
I mean he is good and he can't do anything else
but good God is good.
I love that this psalm begins in verse one.
Truly God is good.
ASAP knows it, but watch what he does. He makes a mistake.
God is good, but the next word is in the next verse,
but God is good,
but as for me, I look at my circumstances,
that's a very important
but right there when you put a
but in that sentence, God is good,
but you're gonna focus on whatever comes after the but
and negate what came before the buts.
I know God is this,
but we can't do that.
God is good, period. No but's about it, right?
He is good. We can't do that.
Remember, don't evaluate God's character
by your circumstances.
Evaluate your circumstances by God's character.
We also know Romans 8 28,
God works all things for good.
He's not only good,
but he works all things for good to those who love him,
to those who are called according to his purpose.
Listen to that. God is good.
He has a good plan and a good purpose for you.
Now, please hear that His good
is not the world's version of good.
It may not include good health or wealth
and stuff or fame or a position.
God's good for you is your sanctification.
Verse Thessalonians four, three, that you
conform to the image of his son,
that you become more like Christ,
that's God's good in your life
and sometimes that requires difficulties in your life.
Can God conform you to the image
of his son while you have an easy life?
I know you don't want to hear that
'cause we all pray, Lord, give me an easy
life, but wait a minute.
An eternal perspective is Lord, make me more like Christ
and that requires difficulties in your life.
God is good and he'll use your circumstances for good truth.
Number one, you can trust him.
Truth number two, ASAP reminds himself, God is is sovereign.
God is sovereign. It's a big word.
It just means that he's in control of all things,
even your life and your circumstances.
Even the wicked, look at verse 18.
Once he goes to the sanctuary and he, his eyes are open
and he gets an eternal perspective.
Verse 18, truly you God set them the wicked
in slippery places.
You make them fall to ruin
how they are destroyed in a moment swept away
utterly by terrors.
Wait a minute. If God sets the wicked
and slippery places, God is in control.
If he causes them to fall to ruin, God is in control.
God is sovereign.
Even when we think things are out of control,
he is in control.
Verse 27, skip down to 27 for behold, those
who are far from you will perish talking about the wicked
you have destroyed all those who are unfaithful to you.
God is not only sovereign
but in his sovereignty, he is the judge of all men.
Small and great. God is the judge. He's your judge.
God is sovereign and he's judged.
Things might seem out of control.
The wicked might seem like they are prospering,
but they have to answer to him one day.
It may not be today, but it will be in his time.
God will judge all men small and great
and many of them will be destroyed.
He will sentence them to destruction.
Asaf says, and he's right. God is good.
Truth number one, God is sovereign. He's in control.
Even when you think things are outta control,
he's in control.
You can trust him. Truth number three,
God has perfect understanding.
You do not. Neither do I.
What I mean by that is he's wise, he's all wise.
He knows what he's doing. He knows why things are happening.
We don't necessarily, our understanding is deficient.
It's lacking and ASAP recognizes that.
Look at verses 21 and 22.
Remember, he's in the presence of God.
He's getting an eternal perspective
and he says this, when my soul was embittered,
when I was angry with you, God pricked in hard.
He was torn up inside I was brutish.
British means without sense. I was senseless and ignorant.
I was foolish. He's admitting his shortcomings.
I was like a beast, an animal just reacting
to my circumstances.
Animals react, right?
They don't think through things, they just react.
I was like a beast Before you, God, notice why
Asaf was brutish and ignorance.
This is very interesting.
He was embittered and pricked and hard.
He was torn up inside. In other words, his thoughts,
his emotions, his feelings got the better of him.
Did you hear that? Sometimes your thoughts, your emotions,
your feelings get the better of you
and that's why God says, trust in me with all your heart
and do not lean on your understanding
because your understanding is going
to be tainted by your emotions.
What you're going through at the moment. Don't do that.
Your understanding is deficient, his is not.
I wanna just go off on a tangent, a couple
of points right here that I thought of as I was thinking
through how we understand things, our perspective
of things and a couple of things.
I think ASAP notes ASAP saw
how good the wicked had it
and he thought that he should envy them.
Look again at verse three.
I was envious of the arrogant when I saw the
prosperity of the wicked.
When you're trying to understand things around you,
you need to understand this.
Other people are not your standard for imitation.
God is your standard for imitation.
Paul said, imitate me as I imitate Christ.
When you focus on what others have or what others do
or don't do or don't have to do,
you get discouraged, you get discontent.
When you begin to look around you
and look at compare your lot to others, all
of a sudden you're unhappy.
You're angry with God saying That's not fair.
Take some time to look at all the pronouns used in Psalm
73 verses four through 12.
He starts out with they, they get to do this
and they get to do that and
and then about halfway through verses 13
and 17, he's looking at himself, I don't have this
and I don't have that and my life's miserable.
He's looking at other people
and he's comparing them to himself
and he doesn't come to his senses until verses 18 to 28.
All of a sudden, the pronouns change to you God.
He got his eyes off of what was around him
and turned his eyes to the Lord.
Don't focus your attention on
what others are doing what they have.
Focus your attention on the Lord
and you'll get a right perspective.
Second little tangential note here,
ASAP looks at the world
and he believes that they are better off than he is.
Listen, the world is not better off than you are.
It's easy to think that sometimes, but it's not true.
The world might seem successful
and rich Bible tells us in God's eyes
they're poor and miserable.
Their lives are shallow, unstable, slippery,
ASAP says they're chasing things that don't last,
that don't matter, that don't count.
In the end, your life is built on the rock.
Their life is built on the sand.
During difficult circumstances, you have a faith
that is eternal
and unshakeable worth the sacrifice
that you're having to go through.
Truth number one, God is good.
God is sovereign and he has perfect understanding.
You can trust him. Truth number four,
ASAP reminds himself that despite your failures,
God is faithful.
Despite your failures, God is faithful.
He will never leave you or forsake you.
The Bible says He walks with you
through your circumstances.
God is faithful. Look at verses 23 and 24.
Nevertheless, he says,
after all he said, nevertheless, despite all of that,
I am continually with you.
You hold my right hand like a father does, a child
with your counsel, with your words.
You guide me again like a father
and afterward receive me to glory.
You know, you and I are prone
to abandon God when things get difficult,
he will never abandon us.
We can trust him to keep his promises.
We can trust him to keep his word even though we don't
regularly keep our promises or keep our word.
God is faithful. He was faithful yesterday.
He'll be faithful to you today. He'll be faithful tomorrow.
God is faithful. Asaf nearly
slipped or stumbled.
Rather than evaluating God's character by his circumstances,
he evaluated his circumstances
by God's character and you know what?
His crisis came to an end. Let's finish up here.
How did as a's crisis end simple.
There was a change. Remember the definition
of crisis at the beginning.
Crisis produces change,
so what changed?
Well, you'll find out
that a ASAP circumstances didn't change,
but his perspective of them did.
Your circumstances may not change,
but your perspective of your circumstances can change.
You and I have very little control in this world.
I hope you figured that out by now.
There's very little that you can control.
You can't control much of what happens to you, but you
and I have 100% control of how we respond to
what happens to us.
Let me say that again. You may not be able to control
what happens to you, but you can control
how you respond to what happens to you.
I said earlier, the truth is you will always have crazy
circumstances in your life.
If you're not going through them now, you're about to.
Those aren't gonna change.
What can change our perspective of our circumstances.
When you know who God is
and what he says, then your crises,
your crazy circumstances won't overwhelm you.
Notice how ASAP finishes Psalm 73, verse 25.
After all he is been through, I almost slipped.
I almost stumbled. I tried to figure this out.
I got into God's presence. He got an eternal perspective.
He's reminded himself of the truths that
who God is and what he says.
He says this, whom have I in heaven but you.
He reminds himself that the focus comes back to God.
Whom have I in heaven but you
and there's nothing that I desire besides you.
As long as I have the Lord, he's all I need is
what ASAP is saying.
He's come full circle here, hasn't he?
A relationship with God? Let them have their money.
Let them have their prosperity. Let 'em have their health.
All I want is God.
He's the only thing I desire on this earth.
Have you come to that place in your life
where you've recognized that there's nothing on this earth
that you need, nothing on this earth will satisfy you.
You could have it all and you would be disappointed.
Empty, shallow and miserable.
Don't believe me. Just read some of the biographies
of the wealthiest people in the world, musicians
and athletes and movie stars.
You can have it all and be disappointed and shallow
and miserable, whom have I in heaven but you.
Your hope in this life
and the next is
not anything in this world.
Your hope in this life in the next is Christ.
He is all you need.
Whom have I in heaven but Christ
and nothing on this earth I desire but him.
Can you say that today
as SAS circumstances had not changed,
but his perspective of them had changed?
Look at verse 26.
My flesh and my heart may fail,
but God is the strength of my heart and my portion forever.
Remember, he said, the wicked are are uh, healthy
and strong, and I wanna be healthy and strong.
I'm sick all the time. Right? He was comparing himself.
Now he says, you know what? His perspective has changed.
My flesh and my heart may fail.
God is the strength of my heart and my portion forever.
At some point, your heart
and your flesh, your body will fail.
If the Lord doesn't come back, death awaits us all.
Your body is temporary.
It's broken, it's weak, it's fragile,
it's perishable.
Paul says, and the next, you can't take your body
with you into the next life.
It's perishable. You need an imperishable body in the next
life and there's only one person
who can give you an imperishable body.
It's Christ. You'll
lose this body
and you'll be given a glorified body
without any frailties.
Sicknesses. My heart
and my flesh may fail me,
but God is the strength of my heart and my portion forever.
He will give you eternal life.
Life without any frailties. Sicknesses.
His perspective has changed even though his
circumstances have not.
Finally, he finishes in verses 27
and 28 verse 28.
We've mentioned 27 verse 28.
As for me, it is good to be near God.
I have made the Lord God my refuge that I may tell
of all your works.
Remember, he started off with, I know God is good,
but this is what I see.
He's come full circle
and he says, it is good for me to be near God.
I've made him my refuge. I desire nothing else.
You are all I have. Forget my circumstances.
I want to be near God.
He ends by saying, basically, I want
to be near God at all times.
I want to trust him at all times.
I want to tell others about him at all times.
That is life right there.
To know Christ, to be like Christ,
to be with Christ, to tell others about Christ.
Asaps circumstances have not changed,
but his perspective of them had.
I want to close with an illustration.
We're all familiar with a solar eclipse,
smaller object.
Moon blocks a larger object, the sun,
and for a few moments we stand in darkness.
Now, for centuries, solar eclipses have caused
people a lot of anxiety.
People have been afraid of solar eclipses thinking
that they were bad omens
or the world was gonna come
to an end or we're all gonna die.
But you and I know the truth of a solar eclipse today.
Yes, for a few moments we're gonna be in the
dark, but just hold on.
The sun is still there
and we will be in the sun in just a few minutes.
The light will shine. I know
a lot of you are going through some difficult
circumstances right now.
Again, if you're not, you will be soon.
It is so tempting for us
to let our circumstances attract our attention away from God
and and judge his character based on
what we're experiencing,
but we must not allow our circumstances to eclipse
our faith in God.
Don't let any smaller object
get in your way of seeing your God.
Your God is much, much bigger than any circumstance
or crisis you may face.
Don't panic, don't fear.
Trust the Lord with all your heart.
Don't lean on your own understanding.
Evaluate your circumstances in light of
who God is and what he says.
He is good. He is sovereign.
He is wise and his.
His understanding is perfect and he's faithful.
You can trust him no matter what you're going through.
Your circumstances may not change,
but your perspective of them can.